[Music]  Megan Lindsey's time on the voice was  kind of like a fairy tale but today  she's living a bit of a nightmare  warning some graphic photos ahead Megan  first shared this collage at seven weeks  ago that's when a brown recluse spider  bit Megan on the face in her sleep brown  recluse Azhar one of the most venomous  spiders mostly found in the southern  United States since the bite Megan's  been posting progress pictures of her  healing process it's been a long one  she even sought out hyperbaric chamber  treatments to speed things up yeah  absolutely  this is what the wound that looked like  32 days after it happened  still through it all Megan has been  working touring with her new music  [Music]  you